vsauce kevin here and i'm auctioning off
the ultra rare playstation 5 jake roper
prepare to cry edition which evokes the
frustration and heartbreak of jake's
fruitless attempts at securing his very
own ps5
with this addition you're buying
countless hours of entertainment and a
monument to one man's
pain
i'm auctioning it using a system of
sealed bids the bidders submit their
price and we determine a winner i've got
four bids ready okay bid number one
hideo kojima my great friend hideo
kojima who i met for nine seconds in
2013 even he can't get a ps5
all right well four hundred dollars
that's pretty undervalued he must be a
very patient and frugal man
the ps5 retails for 4.99 so if this bid
wins kojima is getting
a serious deal alright bid number two
balloon kevin you are not real kevin how
many times
i am real kevin how did you even get in
here well
whatever and what is your pith three
dollars
three dollars okay
balloon kevin is such a scammer what a
stupid bid but i guess maybe he thought
that low balling was worth a shot
whatever
moving on bid number three
oh this bid is actually from jake
himself still desperately trying to get
a ps5
550 bucks that
that's fair it's a 10 premium on top of
the going price which makes sense for
something in such high demand smart bid
jake good luck hopefully we can dry
those roper tears and now to reveal the
fourth and final bid drum roll please
thousand dollars wow that is
that is a serious bid michael must
really really want this thing
that is absolutely what you would call
a pro gamer move
dramatically outbidding everyone to
secure the win and here's something that
you don't realize is so genius about
this this is not a normal auction no
this is a victory auction which means
the winner doesn't pay the highest bid
they pay the second highest bidder's bid
in this case that'd be jake's
550
sorry jake you're uh you're really gonna
want to stay hydrated because those
tears will continue to flow as michael
is playing his brand new ps5 after only
paying your
550
bid so
that's that
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]
wait wait wait wait wait a really really
aggressive bid
worked out this time
yeah but over bidding on a vicry auction
is actually a really really bad
idea and virtually no one realizes that
the most popular auction house in human
history works
this
way here's a question
what are auctions the discipline of
auction theory within economics is built
on a handful of basic auction formats
you're probably used to auctions that
start low and people bid back and forth
until there's only one bidder left the
highest bid wins that's an english
auction or an open bid ascending auction
if you want to get technical you can
also do auctions the other way as well a
dutch auction starts at a price nobody
would pay and descends until the first
person bids and thereby wins instantly
and there are two types of sealed bid
auctions in a normal sealed bid auction
everyone submits their secret bid and
the highest one wins the end then
there's the vickery auction a sealed bid
auction in which the highest bidder
actually pays the second highest bid but
why would you do it that way why not
just keep it simple and how can such a
tiny change in the rules even make a
difference first it's important to note
that we're dealing with an item with
known value there's an established
retail price for the ps5 so we've got a
pretty good sense of what it's
worth millions of people have paid that
price compare that to say
a painting i might think it's a 100
painting painting collector mcgee the
person i just made up might think it's a
25 000
painting i don't know but what about if
the item is like an oil field somewhere
and no one knows what's really
underground that makes it tough to
establish a value yourself but it makes
it really hard to know what other people
might be bidding with a ps5 we've got a
pretty good idea of what other people
might be thinking so
let's say jake figured he'd be up
against someone who might bid at least
as much as the 550 dollars he was
willing to pay
but maybe they'll try to get a deal and
hope that everyone else can't afford it
he thinks they've got a bidding range of
450 to 650 with an equal probability of
submitting any bid within that range so
should he bid 550 so that half the time
he wins half the time he doesn't and
when he loses he's not really out
anything in a standard sealed bid
auction format
now
if he bids over 550 and wins he's losing
value by paying more than he wanted to
so
that's out but if he bids under 550 say
5 30 he'll still win 40 of the time
against the mystery bidder and each time
he wins he's saving 20 bucks
if the highest bid was over 550 he would
have lost anyway the extra value he
gains out of saving 20 dollars four
times out of 10 outweighs that one time
he'd bid 530 and lose to a bid
of 550. that's called bid shading and
it's what nobel prize winner william
vickery solved in 1961 in counter
speculation auctions and competitive
sealed tenders vicry's work on auctions
included the development of the revenue
equivalence theorem which showed that if
an auction satisfies a handful of
conditions the revenue for the seller
will be the same no matter what the
format and for all this he found out he
won the 1996 nobel prize in economics
just three days before he died
so
what's so great about vicry auctions by
making the winner pay the second highest
bid instead that incentive to manipulate
the bidding evaporated and it actually
started to pay to be
as honest as possible vikry ushered in
an era of honest bidding being the
dominant strategy in an auction
let's get back to jake he wants to pay
550 for the ps5 because that's what it's
worth to him if he commits to the pro
gamer move of bidding eight grand just
to guarantee that he'll win the auction
the second highest bidder could be any
number lower than that he could get
stuck paying six hundred eight hundred
four thousand dollars or more especially
if someone else is trying to use the
same strategy inflating his bid not only
doesn't help but could put him in a
really bad position if jake wants to try
to save a little money he can still bid
550 because if he wins he's paying less
than that anyway based on whatever the
next highest bid is he doesn't have to
engage in bid shading and if he does try
to game the system he's susceptible to
being outbid and losing
in a second price auction potential
buyers also have a much harder time
colluding with each other to manipulate
the price in their favor and sellers
just don't have enough information to
successfully plant bids to drive up the
price
in a vickery auction jake's incentive to
go higher or lower than his true value
is just
gone
550 bucks is his best bid but it's not
just best for him everyone he's bidding
against has the same incentive to bid
honestly too the same forces are at work
for them and they know it so why not
just be honest the seller knows no one's
trying to game the system either and
they're gonna get the best price for
their item and
guess what this is pretty much how ebay
works everyone submits their bid and the
winner pays just a tiny bit more than
the second highest bid vikry had no way
to know that almost 60 years after his
paper one single website on the internet
would house nearly a billion and a half
auctions for everyday items worldwide
and virtually everyone would be able to
use his bidding system from a device
in their pockets the 2020 nobel prize in
economics went to robert b wilson and
paul milgram for their work advancing
auction theory and
we've been thinking about a system where
i have something you wanted and we need
to figure out how to exchange it in a
way that's best for both of us
for a
really long time
the greek historian herodotus wrote
about babylonian auctions in 2500 bc and
that's the most surprising thing here
in 4
500 years of thinking about auctions
the mathematical development optimizing
the activity of billions of people is
really close to
just
being honest
and in the spirit of honesty i'm
actually not auctioning off my ps5
because i have demon souls to play and
as always thanks for watching
[Music]
you